two all right for the honorable judge
ethan klein this episode is brought to
you by
fight camp and expressvpn thank you
uh
appreciate that how are you doing today
bailiff i haven't seen you in a minute
all right on the show you may be seated
by the way
thank you previously i know i forgot to
say that
oh thank you garth garth is here in the
uh jury today he's ready to hear us talk
today my friends we have um
someone of great concern to the court
goes by the name of
jared leto the man
is is a clearly
kind of a douche he's a cult leader
and i think he's kind of a bad actor
well that well hold on hold on that's
not that's what a b
thinks i'm just here to check yeah
[Music]
i got to take myself off the bench i am
biased
i have no preconception of jared leto
except what um
the case before us here today that a b
will present um
he's an actor of great renown actually
one like he won an
oscar or emmy or what did he win what's
the deal with that what
i mean he put a lot into that role he's
a method actor he lost a bunch of weight
he put a lot into he does put a lot into
his roles he does
okay well we'll discover that well
congratulations to dallas on the dallas
buyers club there buddy
appreciate you on that jared leto folks
are p are there jared leto stands
they're going to come for us
oh yeah really well as we'll see i mean
the man has a cold
let's [ __ ] go dude am i gonna be
unsafe as a result of this uh video
i can't wait to show you my toys
sorry jared but you didn't method act
that line out enough because that
sounded really bad
all right do we have any opening lines
you want me to read this
jared leto is an actor singer songwriter
oh yeah he's a band member too
he's in the lead singer of the band 30
seconds to mars
he's also been in roles such as dallas
byler buyer's club which you want to
oscar for
and suicide squad which he was
universally uh
lampooned for people say he's the worst
joker of all time not my words
i mean that's his laugh you know what i
mean
that was like a seagull or something so
he's being charged with being detached
from reality being a narcissist and
starting a cult
alrighty let's get started opening
statements a b would you like to uh
open for us thank you yes thank you your
honor yeah i think jared is just
a unique case because he is undeniably a
really good looking guy
and he does have some talent and i think
hold on can we debate that i mean
uh is that up for debate undeniably yeah
i mean i mean
look at the guy dude i got a little lost
in the research on him look at this
beautiful man interesting okay well i
guess we're
we're i guess we've deter maybe has
determined that we all not debate the
merits of his good looks
he's like beyond the reasonable doubt
he's good looking apparently
i think that's true okay he doesn't age
but
yeah and uh i think he's just gonna get
normal human interaction
uh as he started to rise in uh success
and fame and so he kind of got a little
disconnected with reality so
today i hope to take a deeper dive into
his psych
and see if he's gone off the deep end
all righty
looking forward to that ian what do you
think about jared leto what would you
like to say you're wearing a mask that's
very thoughtful of you today ian
what's up what's good wait a-i-e
do you even believe in kovid
i've heard there was someone running
around here that might have
had some sort of illness and i mean
computers don't do very well with
viruses
that's true good point yeah if people
may not know but the real ian actually
has kovid currently but you're not the
real ian so you're fine
yeah but you know you never know what it
might do to an android
sure you know we'll call it freaking
friggin
uh 2077. am i right
no you're right so do you have any
thoughts on a jared leto
look look what he said pretentious actor
name me one that isn't um
anything else you know he's got some
bangers he's got some slamming movies
and also answering this have you ever
met a jared you didn't like
jared fogle jared kushner
jared i mean fogle you can't debate
kushner some people like krishna but the
subway guy
that's a rhetorical
[Music]
well then i would say jared let's go
[Laughter]
all right this chord is now in session
boys let's go
let's open it up part one detach from
reality
what's with the bloody shot what's the
background here
um well i think this is from a movie
where he played a vampire
i hope so at least let's see
so the first exhibit here an interview
with zane lowe will smith said he's
never spoke with jared leto because he
was always in character
after six months of working together
will said he has yet to meet jared
you know i find these kind of method
acts are just a little bit [ __ ] much
especially when you're not even that
good of an actor sorry it was
it was it was uh this was for what was
the name of it the suicide squad which
was like everybody kind of agreed with
the worst movies like what's the rating
on suicide squad could you pull that up
for me real quick dan
yeah suicide squad yeah it looks
ridiculous oh man that thing is
insane yeah i mean jared's a buddy i
mean we know what joe is like as a
person maybe you don't maybe you only
know the joke
about this i've never actually met
jared leto right so we worked together
for
six months and we've never exchanged a
word
outside of action and cut we've never
said hello we've never said good day
i've only ever
spoken to him as deadshot and him as the
joker
i literally have not met him yet
so he's complaining that it's almost not
even a method acting thing it just seems
like he was like just bouncing as soon
as
the scene was over like why wouldn't you
say hi to your co-star that's odd
it's a little bit just douchey yeah just
douchey
also will smith's kind of a big deal
like you think you would want to say hi
to will smith
i wonder if method acting like i do
wonder what real
professional actors think about method
acting
because i feel like there's like a point
where it just becomes kind of cheap in a
way
and almost like overcompensating i
forget who said this
it was a famous actor someone was asking
him and he says he goes
it's he goes you just you act
you don't have to [ __ ] pretend to be
in character for six months
you just that's the profession you just
act
you know what i mean and also it's like
what good did it do you the guy thought
he was going to win an oscar or some
[ __ ] for [ __ ] joker but he ruined the
he like made the joker like the lamest
character for a year
but i mean dude you got to say hi to
will smith i mean that's just
and also you got to tell will smith was
a little annoyed otherwise he wouldn't
be talking about it like that
i get the vibe that he was yeah he's
like dude come on
it's not that serious it's suicide squad
bro it's not like daniel day-lewis
[ __ ]
playing abraham lincoln dumb ass
douche he don't want me man
all right interesting jared sent margot
robbie a dead rat on set of suicide
squad
okay he's in his character so he's on
the door
and uh this guy walks in this you know
tough looking guy walks in he says i got
a message from mr jay
and i was like yo man the [ __ ] security
[Laughter]
like some dude just walked into
rehearsal right and he puts a box down
on the table in front of margot and he
says that's a gift from mr j
and honor your relationship right
and i was like oh mr j oh mr jay okay
okay so marco you know starts to open
the box
and you know there was a note and it was
like from the joker and i say oh okay
that's cool that that's funny jared is
like taking it real serious
i don't think i think it's pretty easy
to tell that will doesn't respect him
and margot opened the box
and there was a live rat in the box
wait i thought it was a dead rat that
oh okay is it alive or is it dead
there are conflicting reports
clearly reports at a later point he
completely
um said that he didn't send them
anything oh
yeah the story kept changing so that's
the like can i just say that like
how dumb that is i mean the joker like
okay let's assume the joker's real
here's a rat in a box epic yeah okay
dude
cool you're in character now
[Applause]
you believe that laugh all right so okay
whatever he's he's
doing his thing okay viola davis said
that jared sent her a dead pig who is
was she also in suicide squad yes yeah
okay so was the pig that or alive
well let's find out i'll find out you're
in the joker
he did some bad things jared leto did he
gain
some really horrific gifts he had a
henchman
who would come into the rehearsal room
and the henchman came in with a dead pig
and plopped it on the table and then he
walked out
and that was our introduction into jared
leto now i'm terrified just as a person
thinking is he crazy
but the second part was oh [ __ ] i gotta
have my stuff together
you talk about commitment and then he
sends margot robbie
a black rat it was still alive in a box
she screamed and then she kept it
what advice would you give to a 10 year
old girl i say it to my dog
oh not nothing bro that's
my advice to a 10 year old girl all
right
i mean dude again he's trying i don't
know okay so you put a
pig on the table and then what they need
to clean it up
he's the joker bro it's not his fault
problem so apparently he said
again again will smith i don't think he
[ __ ] around with this kind of [ __ ]
jed leno sent him anal beads and a used
condom
and this is will smith who's like i have
not even talked to this dude
and he's sending me anal beats like bro
you got to say hi before you send me
anal b's
why why anal bits what is that supposed
to mean exactly
will smith is probably like bro i didn't
play with that [ __ ] let's see what he
said now how about the gifts you gave
everyone rats bullets a hog
where did that come from don't forget
the anal beads
where did you send anal beads to the
used condoms
do not uh yeah used by who because i'm
pretty sure
that's not that funny used by who that's
not funny at all
like that's kind of actually kind of a
real assault like sexual crime
to send someone you know and i think
will was like trying to be like yo this
shit's so [ __ ] up i'm not gonna
mention the anal beads but he's like oh
i gotta talk about the anabis will smith
let's see what he has to say about it
now house pretty much use condoms do not
uh yeah um
i mean it was it was a step back you
can't just say use condoms
and we're just gonna like forget it i
know it's a family show
but we don't worry we can educate people
here at least they were used
what did you send used condoms to oh
everybody
maybe they didn't want to tell you but
yeah i mean i did a lot of things to to
create a dynamic
to create an element of surprise
of spontaneity
and uh and to really break down
any kind of walls that may be there i
mean the joker is somebody
who doesn't really respect things like
personal space or boundaries
yeah we we got god jared said we can't
just keep his objective was not
he says i was trying to tear down walls
yeah and there's anything
he's a [ __ ] weirdo not the joker that
would only cause
more walls i'm an actor i i can pretend
to be
scared or uneasy around you on film
right
you don't have to make my time on set
you don't need to actually
threaten my life for me to be scared
send people bullets and [ __ ] it's like
dude we're all
actors just die for me with your name
you get a used condom what do you say
what do you think
you know you say jared has gone full
joker jared he went he went full joker
you know and the rule generally yeah
zach where's this
where's the world's smackdown but it's
what the [ __ ] seriously
i'm sorry like how often do we actually
get to listen to will smith come on bro
hit me with it
full joker but but he went oh why don't
you go full joke you never go back
really he really set the tone you know
he wasn't
he wasn't playing with it he was dead
seriously after he was going in
and he was 100 going into this character
and he really jarred the rest of us into
okay
okay he's not fooling whatever he did
didn't work because that movie was
[ __ ] horrible did you get the ratings
yeah
it's got a 40 on metacritic yeah what
about imdb what about
uh it had a 6 out of 10.
that's not as bad as i thought on imdb
it has this what about rotten tomatoes
give me that
tomato that's the real one 27 there it
is
that's really bad right that's horrible
that's unwatchable
so jared leto definitely said that
set the tone basically the tone is like
everyone stay away
from this guy the tone is we can't wait
to be done with this [ __ ]
movie and be acting with this freak when
we have a
after party who is not invited
right that's the time everyone want
drinks in my house afterwards
not you not you okay so later on he
denies giving gifts
uh has used condoms i think legal was
probably like
you know what probably happened he was
like i gave used condoms to everyone
nobody wants to talk about it though
because legal was probably like okay
this is illegal
yeah this is horrifying we cannot tell
people they definitely don't mention the
question so he goes on the red carpet
he's like oh yeah i was giving used
condoms everyone and now
they're like yeah you you have to you
have to take that back otherwise
you know yeah we're going to be in a lot
of trouble let's see what he said but
most of it was totally [ __ ]
what exactly did people get wrong about
the joker i mean i just think that there
were some things
you know that were mentioned about like
gifts
and the fact that i was giving used
condoms to people which was not true
literally just said that you just said
that you
have it on video do i need to go back
we got hard i think my synopsis is
definitely what happens you have to you
have to take that back
literally jared has been known to go
deep in his method acting in the past
according to article written
and the rolling stones about the dallas
buyers club he made his first contact
with director
jean-marc valle in a skype call and was
already in character as rayon
even though he didn't have the part yet
he was dressed as a woman valet says
he was hitting on me and he kept it up
for 25 minutes ballet and mcconaughey
never met leto on set only rayon
he tried to steal things from me says
mcconaughey literally my pocket knife
letters etc
that's just annoying no he sounds
obnoxious sorry
matthew mcconaughey he's always
definitely annoyed of him
really well let's watch i feel like
matthew mcconaughey
is let's get some howdies going right
that we would definitely do holidays
then he would do
i think he does method acting but like
in a more traditional way
like a not in a way that makes you a
totally
unlikable [ __ ] i often ask
why did you pick jared and i go i'm i'm
sorry i didn't pick jared charlotte
picked us
pick the film because when i skyped with
him
he had read this i could tell by
mcconaughey's body he had a wig on
he was putting on lipstick he had a
dress on he was playing some mark bow
and
he was hitting on me
so mark i like your voice
i guess it worked baby oh that's
it so where did you say that you saw
evidence that mcconaughey doesn't like
him oh that
they'll be in the later chapter i kind
of want to watch more i like that
he says it's more in the next chapter
yeah on the same video
yeah it's the same video besides acting
jared has held many other
incidents that show how out of touch
with reality he is
uh on the 17th anniversary of kurt
cobain's death jared released a tribute
video
as him
should i read this excerpt he wrote in
his blog i heard today was the day kurt
pat what do you mean you heard today
like oh you just heard it's like if you
care about him i think you would know
you know i heard
can't believe it's been that long so
grateful for his contributions and
inspirations not sure i'd be doing this
if it weren't for him
you give us all permission to create no
matter what our skill set
and reminding me that dreams are
possible did you just call kerpa
kurko being a shitty musician he
literally said
he gave permission for us to create no
matter what our skill set
are thanks for that this made me recall
a short piece of film i shot
when i heard they were making a film
celebrating his life i made it to
explore the character
and explore creative possibilities i
never sent it to the studio or anyone
but thought i'd share it now
[Applause]
your honor if i may interject um i'm not
sure if this will be claimed
now it's gonna be a cover of a nirvana
song
[Music]
he's just playing music yeah but it's
just super weird that he's
dressed as kurt cobain in this
unreleased video that he supposedly had
uh that he showed the public whenever he
found out they were making a video about
him on his birthday or whatever
because like he's not acting he's just
performing a song and then like walking
around like a
zombie you know what i mean like this is
really not that epic dude
jared didn't know about covet 19 due to
a 12-day silent meditation in the desert
i feel like there's nothing necessarily
wrong but this is literally being
disconnected from reality
for sure the actual literal sense well
12 days ago i began a silent meditation
in the desert we were totally isolated
no phones communications etc
we had no idea what was happening
outside the facility walked out
yesterday into a very different world
one that's been changed forever
mind-blowing to say the least i'm
getting messages from friends and family
all around the globe catching me up on
what's going on
your silent meditation may have caused
covet though
that's so thoughtful i don't like that
he refers to it as the the facility
this is bad vibes right there we had no
idea what was happening outside the
facility right that isn't that it sounds
like a mental facility like what's a
facility
that sounds so like corporate you're out
in the desert bro what facility are we
talking about
he was on ellen had an awkward
performance after a shot
after a shot showing an empty stage the
camera then does a dramatic 180 degree
turn to reveal the band is in fact
sitting in the audience
wow epic let's go
no sound oh should we not have sound on
this
probably not might get us claimed okay
[ __ ] it
there's nobody on stage but they are
in the audience psych
what i'm trying to gauge the reaction of
the girls there next to him
it's funny because they're trying to
sing along but no one knows the words
because it's a new song
and it's all like middle-aged like
housewives it's very uh
awkward see that's the risk when you're
you don't want to show the audience that
much because
let's face it they don't know the words
we can't hear
even a little bit let's give it let's
just get a little taste
[Music]
yo what happened here eventually walks
to ellen
who's awkwardly sitting in front of the
choir well they all stood up they're all
coordinated and i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't get claimed for this [ __ ]
this is what it sounds like ellen's up
there
trying to act like she cares
yep okay okay anything else yeah
all right a i n go ahead
what say you on behalf of
jared leto are we the charge is detached
from reality but i really think it's
just being a douche if i can
maybe uh recalibrate the charge a little
bit oh well
he was he was a little over the top on
oscar winning film said suicide squad
that oh whoa whoa whoa what oscar did
suicide
suicide squad win i um
i think it was a hair and makeup yeah
oscar-winning
bruh for your makeup suicide squad
right okay what do you want an oscar for
dollars buyers club because he took the
role too seriously
oh whoa he's just throwing oscars around
whoa what a bad guy
what about sending used condoms to cast
members
hey look what matters is
that the role uh
made an impact on people very memorable
joker role
i gotta say arguably the best
[Applause]
and i have a piece of evidence to show
just how impactful this joker role was
um it even impacted our very own
prosecution
mr a.b really
objections who are you dressed as here
move out the way
move
this is truly a remarkable moment
ian you're still covering it yeah
ian you're still covering i just want to
see the whole thing i mean star
wars it's just star evidence you keep
covering it to the side
there we go there we go wow
wow this is a truly shocking moment for
this
take a courtroom he has a really
compelling point what an
influence on pop culture that you the
prosecution itself
would dress as him a b what can you
possibly say to that
i mean everyone you caught me
i mean i feel like everyone's been the
joker and harley quinn for like the last
three years
but uh you're supposed to his clay maybe
that's what he's saying
yeah but that's the problem the problem
is his influence i don't think he's
necessarily a bad guy i think he just
has uh
i almost drank the kool-aid what could i
say yeah
oh this is really not this is falling
apart
i think the case needs to be thrown out
it's falling apart a.b what the hell
amy do you have anything to say uh what
do you have to say
okay i have something to say tell me
give me something
my wife does makeup in special effects
and it was very popular that year so i
was trying to be a good husband is that
a crime
[Applause]
i don't know man it doesn't really flow
you have anything else to say um
besides me being uh the uh the one on
the spotlight
i just want to say that in terms of his
method acting for the joker i think he
was trying to like emulate
what uh heath ledger was doing because
he's i mean
heath ledger was known for method acting
and he like locked himself in a motel
to do the joker and i think he kind of
took that idea and kind of just [ __ ]
it all up like he kind of went overboard
and totally missed the point
and thought you know being having the
joker brain as zach would say
is uh sending people use condoms and so
your argument is that he bastardized uh
heath ledger's iconic role as joker
pretty much yeah okay do you think that
you would have done a better joker
oh definitely yeah
but i think anyone oh thank you we're
going to deliberate now dan
yeah i feel like aien
popped the lid right off this definitely
did and with um
ab kind of confessing that he would have
liked that role
and probably would have done better
betterness not that objective
also he goes i drank the kool-aid but
then he tried to get himself together
when he realized it was all falling
apart
i almost drank the kool-aid yeah well
i'm not quite sure he didn't
drink the kool-aid but almost is a
little too close yeah almost as
is in a grenade um
okay but let's consider the charge
douche
detachment from reality overlooking the
facts
[Music]
i think his behavior on the set of
of uh suicide squad alone throws the
whole thing into question you know
not talking to will smith sending ux
condoms and then he says he didn't you
send use constant the whole thing's out
of control
he's definitely a douche and you could
tell that his co-stars don't like him
[Music]
[Applause]
based on that evidence no that is him
laughing as the joker
horrible and we're not mistaken with
that horrible definitely what it is
that's
horrible
horrible acting you know
that being said um
that being said ain't makes a really
good point in that he was
so prolific culturally and a b
reinforced this point
[Music]
so he was a douche but also he was
effective
maybe ultimately it was effective but at
what cost
you know what the cost of not being that
nice to your
actors and colleagues maybe it's not
that bad
that it wasn't that nice to them tell me
because i'm torn between
aien mounting a good defense and the
fact that he is a douche
[Music]
um i think they use condoms
throw it too deep a little too far
and um i think he's guilty of uh
i give a nod of course to a ai in and a
b i hold you in contempt of court
that being said jared leto all the all
that being said i we do find you
guilty as charged for being a douche and
we tend to
do 10 years of bad roles which i believe
is
already a is a several years deep we
could consider that the
time spent what did they say time served
time
served
can't get enough of that laugh all right
moving on
uh actually it's time for a recess oh
it's a recess time okay
let's have a quick recess and we will
continue with the prosecution of jared
leto
[Applause]
listen guys i absolutely hate working
out
but there's a solutions to make it more
fun and exciting
also controversially i not only do i
hate working out but i'm also a wimp
and i get my ass beat by anybody that's
why i would like to introduce to you all
today
fight fight camp
combines the exciting and engaging
aspect of learning boxing and kickboxing
with workout routines to give you the
best of both worlds so that you can
get yakked and be able to kick someone's
ass let's be honest that's what it's all
about in the end of the day
now i probably still get my ass beat
there's no there's no amount of
kickboxing that's going to help me in a
fight but
it definitely helped me lose weight you
know
it's awesome let me tell you about it
it's made for beginners to experienced
boxers
who want to box from home fight camp is
a great way to learn boxing and
kickboxing while improving your fitness
with authentic workouts
all while learning at your own pace from
home six trainers make all the
programming based on their experience
training for fights and they offer a
bunch of different ways to learn
such as their 13-week long prospect path
where you're taught the punch number
system the stance and how to properly
throw
each punch and they don't just teach you
the moves they actually have you use
them
during intense 15 to 45 minute workouts
that continue to remind you to pay
attention to your form
that reinforces that technique you learn
to build
your muscle memory this is really cool
comes with all the gear you need
bike camp comes with the best
freestanding punching bag available
great quality boxing gloves quick hand
wraps for the unique punch tracking
sensors that show you real-time progress
and stats on any ios device that's sick
it shows you how it tracks how good your
punches are being thrown over time
that's super cool and then once you have
all the gear you can choose from
one of six trainers with real fight
experience to lead you through a 15 30
or 45 minute workout
structured like a boxing match three
minutes of work and one minute of rest
that's sick dude like that a lot
um you can it's a great holiday gift too
fight camp is the perfect gift for
anyone who wants to take their fitness
to the next level
for someone who has struggled with
finding a workout that keeps them
excited fight camp is a gift for the
entire family
that you can enjoy and get competitive
on i'm gonna get fight camp
this sounds super fun i've been looking
for like a fun creative way to exercise
because i just hate like hate like
jogging
and running and doing the damn you know
elliptical i want to get there through
some punches
so join me on fight camp fight camp
offers flexible financing
for as low as zero percent apr and zero
dollars down
and right now as a limited time holiday
offer get free shipping and a gift
valued up to 109 with every fight camp
package
just go to jointfightcamp.com h3
that's right get free shipping free
shipping and a gift valued up to 109
with your purchase bring an authentic
boxing and kickboxing gym into your home
with fight camp to get your free gift
just go to join fightcamp.com h3 join
fightcamp.com
i'm gonna join that
earlier this year more than 100 twitter
users
got their accounts hacked into passwords
email addresses phone numbers and more
all
taken from high profile people like joe
biden elon musk
and even kanye west even kanye west
i'm more shocked by joe by even kanye
west
these kinds of attacks are getting more
frequent and more severe
and it's not just twitter it's facebook
ebay
uber adobe yahoo have all leaked data
such as passwords passwords
credit card info and driver's license
belonging to
billions of users look if someone can
hack joe biden
just imagine how easy it would be for
them to hack you
and that's why i used expressvpn to
safeguard my personal data online that's
a really good point to be honest
your data is just screwed these days man
you know according to recent reports
hackers can make up to one thousand
dollars from selling someone's personal
information on the dark web
making people like me and you easy
lucrative targets
but expressvpn steps in kicks down the
door
got a riot shield we got ladies and
gentlemen
we saved him expressvpn is an app that
funnels your data through a secure
encrypted tunnel
so that no matter what device you use
you can have peace of mind
every time you use the internet the app
connects with just one click
it's lightning fast and the best part is
expressvpn works on up to five devices
simultaneously so you and your whole
family can stay
protected if a breach happens if a
breach can happen to powerful
individuals it can easily happen to you
protect yourself with expressvpn the vpn
rated number one by cnet
wired and countless others so
if you visit expressvpn.com h3 right now
you can
arm yourself self self self with an
extra
three months of expressvpn for free
that's e x p r e s s
vpn dot com slash h3
visit expressvpn.com h3 to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back everybody we're here moving
on to our second charge
narcissism i'm ready
he's guilty okay now let's review the
evidence all right
jared called a fan out during a concert
for not standing up
interesting
seriously hey buddy hey yo
you with your fingers and your chin
beard what are you sitting on your
[ __ ] ass for
give me a break this is the 30 seconds
tomorrow show
okay oh my god
if you can stand up you better be up off
your [ __ ] ass right now you hear me
what does he understand what i'm saying
to him
maybe he's got an injury no don't look
behind you i'm looking at you
yes you yes you give the guy a break
thank you very much
[Applause]
are you ready find that man after the
show and kill him she's like
putting his coat on him see he's what he
doesn't understand is that
he himself is the real joker toxic
that was very he doesn't need to pretend
to be the joker he just needs to be
himself
probably would have been a lot better
actually you with your fingers and your
chin beard
like that's more interesting it's like
the joker or someone like that you can
ask for
hey this is a [ __ ] five seconds of
mars concert
my all my fans are gonna rip you to
pieces [ __ ]
everybody stands for me jared leto
[ __ ]
he's such a thick hey
hey buddy pretty good that was good
hey buddy jared went to the met gala
with his head as an accessory
and made a commercial out of it
apparently what is this video
preview
[Music]
really you think it's that epic it
doesn't even look that good bro what was
this video
there's just a vogue preview of the
matte gala
okay go ahead ela i don't hate that
okay elijah likes it
there you go that's all i have to say
ooh
do you like that
jared is one of those douche celebs who
used voting as an excuse to show off his
body that's pretty awesome
he tweeted out happy hump day p.s don't
forget to vote how are these connected
because uh
that was the image oh it was attached oh
yeah
why why doesn't it show yeah wouldn't it
show it underneath the tweet i don't get
it
i'm just expanding it so it looks like
it takes some more room okay so you
edited it
sounds like evidence too he just
separated the text of the tweet from the
picture that's all
okay i mean look at those abs we gotta
we gotta admire something
you did say early on that he's
objectively good looking and
you are presenting some evidence to back
that up i suppose okay but
the point is guys is that he said don't
forget to vote and this was the picture
attached what do we think eula
wow vin diesel
so you don't discriminate based on
gender
she's so [ __ ] beautiful vin will take
whatever comes his way i get the feeling
he's a wild one
ila thoughts am i right or wrong
considering like
is the full package of his personality
i hate this in fact if it was someone
actually funny then maybe this could
have been funny to me
no maybe no no no i don't like it
no i don't think there's any good way to
do it yeah the thing is he could post a
video of his body any day it doesn't
have to be like go vote
right happy hump day that's wednesday is
that a sexual innuendo
yeah what do you think about his abs
have you visited blocked
right what do you think about his abs
they're good yeah
and he's got that v thing going down to
his dick pretty good too right
pretty good yeah nice job i want to
smell fit
you wanna i never said that i never said
that if you wanna record it
no um no i don't think so do you want to
[ __ ] jared leto
no okay no would you like to be in part
of
his cult absolutely a chance to smell
his ass
that's a chance to smell his underballs
absolutely not
no okay just check him i think that's
pretty douchey but hey whatever if
you've got a body like that i'd [ __ ]
tweet it out every day
chilled [ __ ] such a [ __ ]
jared felt that the joker didn't get
enough screen time and suicide squad
love that
oh my god is even complaining were there
any that didn't get cut from
they got caught from the movie no i'm
asking you were there any that didn't
get cut for the movie
well to the people who want more joker i
say
uh me too yeah okay
i did a lot of work in the film uh and
the sock was
so they had to cut it so i have get the
memo
yeah i have a feeling that it wasn't
good if they cut it out you didn't do a
good job
but also like as an actor it's a it's
really kind of like
i feel like not perfect unprofessional
it's like clearly the director who hired
your ass yeah the vision for the film
include your [ __ ] being the star
exactly it's like dude shut the [ __ ] up
but but what about the jared fans they
wanted more jared leto
i gave people used condoms i was in
character for six months and didn't even
say hi to will smith
well to the people who want more joker i
say
uh me too yeah
i did a lot of work in the film and you
got paid for it
was cut so
um you have to ask the movie studio
why you asked the director bro and and
yes uh i'd like to see a little more
joker and suicide squad too we shot so
much footage there are that's part of
the gig not in the film
oh there were so many scenes that got
cut from the movie i
i all right you don't make your own
movie whining
wait till you hear about so he was
apparently
i'm assuming this is coming up very
upset about the joker with joaquin
phoenix
that did really well is that in here a.b
uh yeah
but this to be uh to be uh coming up
later apparently
yeah to be transparent though it was it
wasn't confirmed
it was confirmed by me jared was oh it's
right here
jared was not happy about the new joker
movie starring joaquin phoenix according
to hollywood reporter
leto tried to stop the new joker film
from being made
lettuce team denied the claim that he
tried well we also saw him claim he
didn't give people used condoms so the
guy
you know what i mean he tried to stop
the movie from being made
on your [ __ ] ass for because he was
mad that he wasn't cast in it
can you imagine he would have ruined
that film which was great
it was a great film bro you don't have
the acting chops i'm sorry
also after you complained so much i
doubt anyone would hire him again
i cut uh i would like to see more joker
too i was cut
they cut everything my friends it's like
you were in the film bro how much could
they have cut it's like
you're not the main story it's an
ensemble yo you got your fingers in your
chin beard
for them but jared leto feels left
behind the hollywood reporter
reports that he bitterly complained to
the agency that represented him
which he left this summer presumably
over this whole disagreement
he even tried to get the movie cancelled
to the guy who manages his band
30 seconds to mars why is leto so
butthurt
after all he did kind of dig his own
grave here are a few possibilities
jared leto is not happy his future is
the joker has been cancelled
handed over to joaquin phoenix yeah so
what exactly is leto saying and why is
he so mad
let's find out this is an obvious one
but joaquin phoenix's version is just a
better movie
so much better now so much better you
can say that again
joker is so much more entertaining
characters so much more never human
never got
the other hand was a bust it was
directionless
loud and disappointing take a look at
their rotten tomatoes numbers for
example
should i keep watching this or she
already said all that yeah i think we
got the idea
i'm just gonna watch this guy's youtube
video
but um yeah i mean i it doesn't take a
stretch of the imagination to believe
any of that
and the fact that he left the agency too
jared tried to publicly call out the
producers for not giving him a straight
answer to whose idea it was to hire him
he's thought that obama well here i'll
just play the video
robbie whose idea was it to put me i
can't i mean i hear now i i
i barack obama called me the other day
said you know i was my
idea for you to play rayon in dallas
buyers club
whose idea was it i mean no exactly
nobody was that a joke
did you see him at you dude matthew
mcdonough [ __ ]
hates him he didn't even smile matthew
mcconaughey thinks he is such a piece of
[ __ ]
just look at his face here now it's some
howdy
barack obama called me the other day
said you know i was my idea for you to
play
rayon and dallas buyers club
he's not even going to talk about that
certainly nobody was thinking about
putting me in a film
actually that's not true um it actually
was not the president of the united
states what
yes barack called
[Music]
that plays out and he's still like
trying to hound her and she's like well
that's the truth i don't know let me i'm
gonna watch i'm curious now robbie whose
idea was it oh come on
here now i i i barack obama called um
suggested uh suggested you and said and
and also jason we were having
conversations with him we were
you know trying to cast the movie you
know how casting usually works
that's what happened um rachel and i
said
that's a fantastic idea and we regret it
till this day
shall mark this the narrative always
changes it's awesome
i'm gonna make it better or worse i
think spike jones could nail this one
a movie about a movie about a movie
about who put that person in the movie
well this is the way it really happened
actually you know what at the end of the
day
i love the one left ah
he says at the end of the day who cares
yeah
it's like look i got my cult they love
me that's all them is
i don't know why he's so obsessed with
the mythology of who hired him was odd
and then she's like yeah it was just a
normal casting situation oh
now they're really changing the story
okay bro
you could just tell matthew mcconaughey
who by the way
lincoln i don't know if you've seen his
link commercials he's the coolest
[ __ ]
so if he hates jared i'm hating jared
jared can't watch his own films he
mentions he can't watch his movies
because he is a control freak
he mentions it would be excruciating
that's normal as a side note matthew
mcconaughey is sick of jared leto's
[ __ ]
i think i'll watch it at some point um
you know if i was directing a film and
in the edit room and making editorial
decisions
i've done that i've by the way i give
that i give the academy award to
matthews for hating him so much and
working on screen with them yeah
like so much he actually did win best
factor though
he did really well in that would
probably
movie
excruciating for me to just sit back as
a self
confess control freak wait what was that
just based on his mannerisms abe the
description
yeah his mannerisms and saying that he's
the control freak i think i'll watch it
at some point
um thinks he knows better than the
directors basically
jared sharing memes about himself also
highlights his self-love
my brother put this picture of jared
leto on the wall and now my grandma is
worshiping
him under his eye
why does your mouth look like isn't that
a saying from something
does that look good no isn't it from uh
handmaid's tale
oh oh yeah it is under his eye oh i'm
not surprised he's into that how y'all
doing today you doing
good [ __ ] balls [ __ ]
this this is what happens when you're so
attractive that you're and you're just
so talentless that you can
fall upwards this is what falling
upwards looks like
only a narcissist would think that this
is a good robot oh
wait what is this we have a gift
yeah what the [ __ ] wait let's get a
reaction wait hold on we have a reaction
gift in the
evidence it's this a b yeah that's had
to be amy
it's charlie murphy we got we gotta hold
on hold on i got a set of ground
no reaction gifts all right this case is
thrown out
and the evidence we've done we've done
it before oh we have we've done we have
we must have maybe i like it maybe we do
like it we do not like it
maybe we do though we do not like let's
watch the clip and decide
i don't like it all right let's watch
i don't like it
i like it you do that's a sound bite
[Music]
oh my god you got me why don't i get
claimed on this
dumb phone where's the robot exactly
well he kind of did it
and he's gonna do it again in a second
okay
wait what the [ __ ] did i miss that's it
that's that's that's
his moves those are his dance moves oh
he was dancing
oh i didn't realize he did a run but who
cares we're making fun of his best
wait come on this is a reaction gift for
the guys
he was just vibing out on stage i can't
wait to show you my
toys wow jared's tick tocks are an act
of narcissistic cringe let's see
how it's mutated [ __ ]
all right because this video
on the right i don't know if you're
familiar with this trend it was
basically
uh people would duet this video of these
girls screaming and going crazy and they
would put crazy you know different
things in the reaction but
he just put himself like they're all
going crazy over him i see there's a
gucci
bag on the chair there too in frame in
general
that's gotta be gucci right this one
looks like it
so so he's the surprise
it's a tick tock though why are they so
surprised it's him no he's
just expecting it's like an edit oh it's
a meme yeah yeah it's a meme yeah it's a
very popular tick tock trend last year
this is just humiliating
[Applause]
bro what is wrong with you dude for real
he's really used to people reacting that
way to him
crazy
jared allegedly has a thing for younger
women
he's a serial texter he's constantly
texting these 16 to 17 year old girls
it's really kind of creepy someone said
in an article
oh what dylan sprouse and james gunn
call out him on twitter
so jill and spouse actually i don't
we follow each other on twitter right
friends he's but i'm
but i am assuming he has first-hand
knowledge of something of this going
down unless he wouldn't do it but he
even
went as far to tag him so i'm assuming
this happened to someone he knows
yeah yo jared leto now you've slid into
the dms of every female
model aged 18 to 25 what would you say
your success rate is
and then james gunn responded wait he
starts at 18 on the internet
so these are guys these are both pretty
big industry people
willing to tweet this publicly about him
makes me very
yeah it's very odd
talk to me baby then or vin diesel's
like what's the big deal
so there's an article about it yeah i
think just about these tweets
huh yeah bam he must be a major crib
jared whispers thank you after your
interviewer moves on without telling him
thank you
oh my god he was offended when she
didn't acknowledge his godly status
went on a climb together and it was uh
beautiful
rachel i have a question for you i mean
the this is obviously a period film
so he went thank you was he saying
yeah he didn't like being moved on from
like that
interesting oh jared creeps on emilia
clarke
we don't allow this our queen
khaleesi why does your mouse look like a
shooting star
it's some [ __ ] uh setting that got
clicked i don't know
hi jared this is amelia clark from game
of thrones
give me a hug for a hug i like that i
like that best season ever
i haven't seen your show but i know
people are obsessed with it and say it's
absolutely bro what kind of
way yeah what an [ __ ] i hate when
people do that to me on the street they
go
they go uh i don't really like your
videos but my brother's a huge fan it's
like well
take a [ __ ] on the road then bro
cause like i i really don't want to
you know but i still want
let me talk to someone who actually
likes me like
thank you um see i know your band and
i've seen your movie
wow yeah look at that he's like i'm a
[ __ ] are you a music girl you like
rock music
yeah fun music yeah thank you amelia
dude you're so awkward
oh are we okay she's not going anywhere
i haven't finished here this work yet to
be done
have you have you had i love you your
eyes are absolutely
i mean insane they're gold and blue and
i was thinking the same thing can we
sort of speak delay this is what i'm
saying
you he's falling out everything he does
has been so easy in life
for being handsome like you know
this would if i was an insult i'd be
pissed watching this
because it's like i'm pissed your eyes
are so beautiful it's green and white
and he's just holding her
super awkward he's not letting her leave
he's bumped he's over
he's basically taking control of her
interview it's all about him though like
look at his body he's like
right my interview now did you see me
and by the way he opens by saying
i'm not familiar with your word he's
such a douche i hate him yeah he's a
mega douche
zoom into her eyes i'm not even kidding
you right jared here we go
here we go let's zoom in this is the
come on
which one am i looking at there we go
look right in that's
that's pretty much it but i'm blushing
wait
he walks away how can we not see his
eyes and how blue and gorgeous
could we do the eye cam with you do it
very well
that's pretty much the majority of it
but at one point yeah like you said she
was walking away and he kind of
pulled her back i want to watch it yeah
i want to watch it all
thank you baby well i love that it
became about how beautiful his eyes are
now
hello amelia how could we not see his
eyes and how blue and poor
could we do that
[Music]
do you want to ask jared anything since
you're here on the e platform with the
microphone any questions
she's like yeah no did you enjoy
thinking how did you grow your hair
you know how did you how did you grow
yourself you know i i slept it grows
while i sleep which is really weird
uh uh
[Music]
what was that one that one i mean it's
more did you feel like it was just an
extension of him being a douche
right what was the charge on that one
narcissism narcissism and the
the original charge of the first section
was was not douche but
but yeah now it's all kind of just
building into a big douchebag
with your fingers and your chin beard on
the charge of narcissism let's say you
you know he's a he's a narcissist but
he's too focused on himself i mean
that sounds familiar have you ever met a
youtuber
bro i've met youtubers oh
well it takes one to no one okay
oh he's pulling up that takes one to no
one defense that's a classic defenseman
no one
takes one to no one clause okay ian i me
and mike and my peers on youtube are not
on the stand here today we are talking
about
if you if you if you charge him for
being a narcissist
under that takes one to no one law you
are admitting
that you are also a narcissist right
to review the judicial code it's been a
long time i i think i heard it
back in elementary school i think that
was in the uh constitution
a b it takes one to no one what say you
in response to that um i say we got to
do it for uh big matthew
i think we owe this this one to matthew
mcconaughey we have to we have to charge
him for
the big mm what to say to the
if you smelt it you dealt it though
because like you denied it
whoever denied it supplied it a i in any
response to that
[Applause]
uh well there's a third part but i don't
have i don't remember it so i gotta look
it up first
interesting not much of a response
well okay thank you i'm not quite sure
what i just heard but thank you uh to
the defense and the prosecution
so okay let's deliberate
jared leto we've established as a douche
is he a narcissist probably based on
that emilia clarke interview where he
just basically just was like hey i don't
know who the [ __ ] you are but i'm here
now so this is a good interview now
yeah it was weird he barely even looked
at her but he complimented her in a way
to get the compliments back at him right
and he was like it's kind of
she's got a whole technique you can tell
she's like well you haven't
seen my stuff but i'm actually heard
your music and i've seen your work and
i'm a fan
and he's like oh i'm gonna [ __ ] you yeah
that's what i got
have you heard by myself oh thank you
very much i'm gonna [ __ ] you right now
yeah he's a narcissist you know what i
mean
right sentence him to getting um
what do we what's his sentence
to being trapped in the facility for two
more weeks
and coming out to a new a brave new
world
uh yeah brave new world but i don't want
to be in his breakfast
[Applause]
third charge cult leader here we go
let's go
let's go
band held an island retreat in croatia
croatia in august 2019 called mars
island now if you're doing
retreats in croatia i feel like that's
automatically yes it's a cult
brought those from croatia as you know
there's a lot of mystery
mysteries going on out there yep there
but but if you have any questions
30 seconds from mars tweet it out yes
this is a call
everybody's wearing white they're
wearing robes he's obviously the cult
leader that
you know [ __ ] all the young girls
obviously
and i mean that's that's what colts are
basically for if you examine any cult
with a singular leader at the top it's
basically the the whole
the whole point of the quote culminates
in him having sex with lots of females
yeah it's amazing what the whole world
that they create around that
but ultimately yeah the bottom line the
purpose of everything
is for the main leader to get [ __ ] yes
all day
by different girls
let's see let's get some more here's
jared leto leading his brother
everyone's wearing white lots of young
women i expect i don't even see a single
guy i mean looking at these photos
um i don't think how are you sitting
there like what exactly does this guy
have to say to all these people yeah
exactly like bro what exactly is your
qualifications you play joker i mean
what the [ __ ]
have you seen the color of my eyes
yeah i mean these are all females i
don't see a single guy in this whole
photo or this one
here's one dude wearing a marvel shirt i
think we talked about had the same exact
conversation before
we were talking about it
yeah i mean he probably [ __ ] like at
least 70 of the people here
footage of the event
does a clip shows jared on a boat that
looks like he's on his way to jonestown
oh boy
bruh what the hell we didn't see this
last time
oh my god would you die for me
that was a joker clip by the way but i
could see him asking that
bro you're holding a mic to your mouth
paid for this bruh could you imagine
doing anything worse with your time
no not not not really not easily no
would you rather sit here or in a
session with bronzo
brought so for sure brought some yeah
he's actually more calming
bro like he doesn't try to pretend he's
like yo i'm just gonna stare at you and
you do whatever you want with that
yeah he's like look i got a weird face
nice hair you can stare at me
yeah i would definitely chill with
bronzo any day i do have it on good
authority though that bronzo does [ __ ]
of course have you seen the women that
pursue anyway this isn't about brought
to you by it's all about [ __ ]
always yeah bro it's about the [ __ ]
always exactly you don't know but i'm
telling you
all right we're not talking about here
yeah but brought so [ __ ] we should
revisit broadside here soon
the ban has already been using the tack
line yes this is a cult for years
really he says it's a joke a response to
a journalist saying you have such a cult
following
you know what i don't like about cults
is that that's part of the way to
normalize
their stupid [ __ ] um
they kind of like pretend like they're
pushing the boundary or it's a joke
but then they're actually doing it what
it is he said
i don't like the word fan base i hate
the word fan
it seems so dismissive because we have
this cult this family these believers
who understand
it seems fitting that there's a name to
reference them yeah
fan isn't enough fan is cringy like i
have trouble saying fan cause what is
fan is a fanatic a fan
someone but a believer no yeah he's
the kite is a lunatic bro but living in
what in your blue eyes so the echelon
that's apparently the name of their
cult the echelon also often uses the
hashtag
you wouldn't understand
well sure wouldn't 30 seconds of march
instagram has many photos where jared
looks like a messiah
yeah is that a joke too you wouldn't
understand hashtag
here's it i don't know what this is
let's find out hey guys it's me
jared 30 seconds to mars but you may
know that we've been working you may
know that
really hard on mars island too we were
able to push it until
august 2021 moving your festival
to next august it's the right thing to
do it's pretty much our own
now why the [ __ ] are they referencing
the guy who put on fire festival
like don't include him
he's like 20 21 the right thing to do
it's like yeah but you did like one of
the biggest festival frauds ever like
yeah why is like i will be working
remote from jail
yeah but i'm putting together this event
yeah i've been put i've been
pulling on all my contacts i even got ja
rule involved
i would call that uh false advertising
job rules already got his
lined up glad to hear it ja roll i
believe in your work man you do good
work
that's not fraud no right no no no no
nobody said fraud
you brought it up it's already saying
fraud i didn't
say anything charles calm down
hey gero when the when a lawyer calls
you up from the state
and says yo where's all the money what
do you tell them
i would call that uh false advertising
right that's not illegal it's different
than fraud
for 2021 on a beautiful private island
in croatia
i think it's going to be a big
celebration that we can all enjoy after
quarantine it feels a little like i'm
living on an island right now but we're
excited about it looking forward to
taking a dip in the sea water sports
beautiful sunsets
i've been known to uh like a good sunset
tattoos that's sandwich
no not that's actually we have
meditation another firefest
bag that was the food from fire festival
something tells me the food's not gonna
be much better i gotta be honest i do
look at that so he's making jokes about
fire festival yeah
so he's really building it up like he's
like
i'm aware of the fire festival and this
is gonna be better
oh yeah this is a low bar though
no not that sandwich record scratch yoga
we have
arts and crafts oh and did i mention if
we're performing i'm a grown ass [ __ ]
man what the [ __ ] am i gonna do arts and
crafts one of my
eight come to grow asian do arts and
crafts
shut up i wanna [ __ ] glue macaroni to
a necklace [ __ ] i'm 30 years old i'm
35 years old man
arts and crafts intimate shows a lot of
fun we've been working a lot of new
music lately
so if you get tickets for mars island
i'm going to be doing a private
zoom about uh 2021 take care guys
we'll see you soon oh my god on sale now
how much are they
can i go to this website next next uh oh
it's there oh good
30 seconds to mars let's go
here we go so 2020 was canceled
obviously 2021
three nights all inclusive uh one
payment of sixteen hundy
that's the lowest that's the low that's
that's the ones where you they give you
basically a blanket and you sleep on the
sand
the stargazer package yeah your ass is
gonna be gazing at the stars because you
don't have a [ __ ] roof
the stargazer package
the adventure package that's what it's
called it's called the stargazer package
right here
that means you don't have a roof
[Music]
then the adventure pack you get a camp
it's three thousand dollars you go if
you go to the next slides i break them
down
[Music]
then you get the wanderer package like
jesus and moses through the
desert or whatever four thousand dollars
there's all kinds of [ __ ] they didn't
even put the price on these next ones
ago you got to contact
us idiot sucker this one
is seven thousand dollars the day deemer
package
you'll be daydreaming about all the
money you [ __ ] wasted
stargazer cheapest let's see so this is
the cheapest one 1600 bucks
three nights meal snacks non-alcoholic
beverages
two full-length intimate concerts
concerts
fairy transportation opening ceremony
with the band photos with the band q a
with jared leto drum circle
was shannon leto was he married his no
his brother's in the band as well okay i
was like
this guy is not a married man island
activities include yoga meditation water
sports film screening workshops what you
doing what about arts and crafts [ __ ]
i'm not gonna read all these but
that's pretty pricey what does this one
get you for
7150 early access to the island
an extra day of act of arts and crafts
priority entry to ban priority entry to
concerts vip activity with jared leto
edition print sound check
wants to sit on a sound check exclusive
vip merchandise
unsigned they're very specific unsigned
access to group conce that doesn't sound
like that great
oh well you get a nicer so is the sound
check
just down by some sound guy i think i
assume the band
one two one two yeah he did check check
check check to some some roadie check
check
stop check oh they've got merch
family 30 seconds tomorrow's holiday
sweater
what is on this it's too far away from
me that's their logo which also kind of
looks like
it's definitely a cross it's absolutely
across
he's not even trying to pretend that
he's like the messiah
hey
all right a-i-e-n jesus is yours go
ahead and try to tell me that this isn't
a cult
uh well yes uh granted they did
themselves actually say yes this is a
cult yes
but as we established earlier jared leto
is a liar that is on the record
in this courtroom he's unreliable
interesting point okay but what about
the evidence
you know shown well also
i'd like to point out i mean when you
think of a cult you think of
kind of like a a big group of people who
are like very pro the cult leader
right like they see them as like a god
essentially
right you agree
i agree so i mean we have discussed
jared in the past
we actually have a highlight about this
well i believe we called it a
weird cult it was a very derogatory
approach
jared leto's weird ass colt now look at
the like dislike ratio
95 positive no
don't you think this this crazy violent
this crazy obsessed cult would be more
ride or die
where are they they took the crisis up
pretty well
i think it's a small cold i think it's
more symptomatic of uh
the size of their cult so all 871
that's the cult and the dislike
bro make a compelling point may i
respond
yes maybe go ahead please they never
left the island they never left the
island
do they have internet on the island
[Applause]
they're left on the island they never
left behind the lights
[Music]
i feel like maybe go ahead
then got it baby got it okay i feel like
just kidding don't go ahead okay you
guys i'll take that back you can go
ahead come on
come on okay ian let me remind you that
you are not sitting at the back i said
he could have the floor you can go
and are you done are you done with
yourself maybe
maybe maybe ian silence
maybe he's going to 30 seconds to
marshall he's gonna do it again
is he trying to make a point ian what's
happening here
i said av can go ahead go ahead go ahead
and go ahead and go ahead
okay yeah no i don't think there's any
technology on just go ahead
one more outburst from you and i will
hold you in contempt and turn your mic
off
go ahead ap stop if there's any
technology on that island it's a
powerpoint
of jared leto explaining why he was a
good joker um
i don't think there's any debating that
that is a cult
uh that being said i rest my case i
would like to know that
the the attributes that makes a cult you
know what i mean i feel like
i'm not sure i i was i was starting to
have my mic turned off over that
[Laughter]
wait there's got to be like a
psychological analysis of this here a b
like there's certain characteristics
that define cult-like behavior
do we have anything like that i mean i
could hold up the definition of a cult
right here
let's read it uh a relatively small
group of people
having religious beliefs or practices
regarded by others
as strange or sinister it's pretty broad
but
can you re-read that as we look at slide
37 i feel like that sums it up perfectly
all those photos i don't know slide them
on but i think you're talking about this
one
yeah it's pretty cold all right let's
let's deliberate or
or maybe running around and literally
blessing your fans
papa blessing your fans non-stop again
ian i am not on trial here
if you want to do a content court on
ethan submit it for
consideration you'll have to sue me
raising your partner
raising your your foot score past
humanly possible levels
i i will remind you in
if you want to file an official
complaint you will do it through
official channels
report boom
boom all right we're deliberating you
guys are done
thanks for nothing as usual
i mean it's definitely a cult right yes
yeah okay he called
jail i sent him to jail
that was fun you know i enjoyed the
unusual
uh yeah target the jared leto
i want to do more like that so
that's done yeah we're done get done
well
i really enjoyed the unorthodox target
jared leto
me too it was really fun it was good it
was a good story
and i want to say thank you to ab
who put this whole thing together yep
fantastic job baby
your powerpoint uh skills are top-notch
i want to thank the defense attorney who
uh actually has covet at the moment so
we appreciate that
not aien but like let's be honest
there's a jeff dunham back there with
his hand
strings and he has kovitz what are you
talking about
so we thank him for that and i've really
in some really compelling arguments from
ian too
just kept us on our toes the whole time
zach of course
that's great man with the sound bites
everywhere today
zach thank you
and dan of course whom let's be honest
without it all
dan is atlas you know what i mean
[Music]
that's not strong that i don't shrug
yeah let's rock him he's carrying us
all on his shoulders absolutely hey dan
that's not bad
[Laughter]
and ela i didn't do anything you put the
egg
come on you put you you what up big
pimps you do it all
i want to smell feet you want this never
said that what are you talking about
it's right there this is the sound bite
of it guys dripping
right you guys are sure play it again i
want to smell feet
i want to smell feet it doesn't even
sound like me it's
literally unmistakable
well this was fun thank you guys i had a
lot of fun here
uh another banker in the in the in the
old
danga freaking uh tan can the tank
yeah content court we'll be back with
another one in a couple weeks you know
these things take time to put together
so
again i really want to thank abe and the
whole team who work to put this together
it's a lot of work
maybe any comments nope you got any
ideas for our next target
i have a few yes oh love to talk about
that
[Applause]
all right guys take care we'll see you
next time
thanks for watching 30 seconds to mars
[Music]
baby
you